the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi in our lesson today we shall try to
find a relationship between line
integrals and double integrals in
particular we shall equate line
integrals along certain types of closed
curves to double integrals over the
region enclosed by the particular closed
curve in particular the title of today's
lecture is green's theorem and in terms
of some particulars I guess the
intuitive notion that we'll have to
accept is the idea of what one means by
a connected region I think this is one
of those times in mathematics where we
can say if you have an intuitive idea of
what the concept means you have the
exact idea of what the concept means
essentially connected means that you can
get from any place in the region to any
other place in the region without ever
having to leave the region it's as
simple as that
okay connected means that you can get
from any point in the region to any
other point in the region without ever
having to go outside the region the
mathematician distinguishes between two
different types of connected regions one
of which is called simply connected the
other of which being the opposite of
simply connected
meaning non simply connected or multiple
connected I prefer multiple connected to
non simply connected because in non
simply connected you don't know whether
you're modifying simply or connected a
non simply connected region when you say
multiple connected means that in
particular the region is connected the
intuitive way of looking at this is that
simply connected means no holes for
example this region here is not only
connected but it's simply connected
there are no holes this region is
connected you see I can get from any
point to any other point without ever
having to leave the region but it's
called multiple connected because there
are holes in the region by the way you
see the trouble with using expressions
like holes versus non holes is that in
that particular case where we're dealing
with two or three dimensions
is certainly no problem because we
intuitively visualize where the hole is
in n-dimensional space and we have
analogs of these results in these n
dimensional space the problem is is that
how do you describe a hole without
referring to a picture and the more
rigorous mathematical definition of a
simply connected region is the following
the connected region and it has to be
connected before you talk about simply
connected you see the connected region R
is called simply connected if it's
complement is also connected remember
the complement is the portion of space
left when the particular region is
deleted for example here we have a
simply connected region
notice that the complement of this
region would be for example the entire
blackboard with this piece missing and
the entire blackboard with this piece
missing is still a connected region on
the other hand if we were to take this
connected region and look at its
complement its complement is this little
hole together with what's outside here
and notice that there is no way from
getting from here to here without having
to go outside the complement you see in
other words the complement of the
multiply connected region is not
connected at any rate whichever way you
want to look at this is fine I think of
simply connected it's least in the two
dimensional cases meaning no holes and
with this as background greens theorem
call it the theorem I guess is stated as
follows suppose R is simply connected
with a boundary see those are is the
region C it's its boundary and a very
interesting thing takes place if you
form the line integral around the
boundary C and by the way with this loop
in here this is the symbol that we mean
around the closed curve the arrowhead is
simply done to invoke the convention and
we do have to pick a convention just
like we did in calculus of a single
variable about positive and negative and
how you move we pick the positive
direction as being the direction in
which one goes around the boundary
so that the region appears to our left
as we go around the boundaries as we're
going around here you see in this
direction the the region appears to our
left and anyway I'll mention that in
more detail later the directed line
integral around the closed curve C MDX
plus NDY
turns out to be a double integral over
the region R enclosed by the curve and
that double integral has as its
integrand the partial of n with respect
to X minus the partial of M with respect
to Y and I will refer to this again very
very shortly but I hope that this brings
the familiar Bell in terms of what we
talked about exact differentials
remember a differential MDX plus NDY was
exact if the partial of n with respect
to X equal the partial of M with respect
to Y I'll return to that in a moment for
the time being all I want you to see is
what greens theorem says what greens
theorem does is it relates and a line
integral along the boundary of a simply
connected region to a double integral
over the region itself the proof of the
theorem is in the Thomas text it's
available in a pretty straightforward
form for anybody who would like to see
the proof of the result I don't think I
want to prove the result in this lecture
I think I would rather have excuse me
hammer home what the theorem says rather
than what this rigorous proof is the
idea is though that what a a line
integral is related to a multiple
integral and all its required for greens
theorem to be true is that M and the
partial of M with respect to Y the
partial of n with respect to X must
exist and be continuous in a region
containing R and we'll see later that
even the condition of simply connected
can be waived in fact in the Thomas
demonstration we don't even deal with
the most general simply connected
regions he gives his proof for a very
specific type of simply connected region
but again that isn't crucial either
we'll talk about that in more detail
later in the lecture
as well as in the exercises the idea
again though is what we're not relating
arbitrary line integrals to arbitrary
multiple integrals but greens theorem
relates a line integral along the
boundary of a simply connected region to
a double integral defined on the
interior of the closed curve C the
region R and there are two interest in
cases one of which we learn more than
two but two that we'd like to talk about
one of the interesting cases we've
already hinted at and that is if M DX
plus n dy is exact then the integral of
M DX plus n dy around the closed curve C
is 0 and the reason for this you see is
that the integral around the closed
curve if by greens theorem is just a
double integral partial n with respect
to X minus partial M with respect to Y
and if M DX plus n dy is exact then
these two terms are equal so that their
difference is identically 0 and to
integrate 0 da over any region R of
course is just 0 itself in other words
then if M DX plus n dy is exact the
integral around any closed curve is 0
and by the way this ties in with a
question that was raised in our previous
lecture and that was we saw that if we
had a force for example and we had a
particle move from the point p0 to the
point p1 under the influence of that
force that the work done is that
particle moved in general depended on
the curve which connected p0 to p1 my
claim is that if the force em I plus n J
has as its components C MN where the
partial of M with respect to y equals
the partial of n with respect to X my
claim is under those conditions the work
is independent of the path and that's
what we mean in turn by a conservative
force field
the proof is quite simple what we do is
is we pick two different paths that
connect p0 to p1 we call one of the
paths c1 and the other path c2 and now
what we're saying is if
we think of C as being the curve that
keeps this region to our left as we go
along here then the integral around C is
zero but what is the integral around C
it's the integral along c1 minus the
integral along c2 and I hope that that's
clear from the exercises of last time
that when you switch the sense of the
path all you do is change the sign of
the integrand in fact by the way while
we're on that topic let's digress for a
moment and return to our statement of
greens theorem and observe that if we
were to switch the convention if we were
to switch the convention and keep the
positive direction as that which kept
the area on our right
notice that this would change the sense
here which should give me a minus sign
but if I interchange you see the order
of the terms here if I reverse the sense
the sign of the integral the double
integral will also change the important
point being that all of these sign
conventions do I preserve by things like
greens theorem and the like but the
important point is getting back to this
now the integral around the closed curve
C is the integral along c1 minus the
integral along c2 and since the integral
along that closed curve is zero it says
that this minus this is zero
consequently these two integrals are
equal and since c1 and c2 we're
arbitrary paths that connect p0 and p1
that shows that the line integral in
this particular case does not depend on
the path but only the points p0 and p1
again we will emphasize that more in the
exercises the second interesting
application of greens theorem is a form
which not only shows us how a line
integral and a multiple integral are
related but it actually shows us a way
of computing an area in terms of a line
integral in particular if in Green's
theorem we let n equal X and m equal
negative Y notice that Green's theorem
then becomes what the integral along a
closed curve C
MDX plus NDY is this minus y DX plus X
dy the partial of n with respect to X is
1 the partial of M with respect to Y is
minus 1 therefore the partial of n with
respect to X minus the partial of M with
the partial of n with respect to X minus
the partial of M with respect to Y is 1
minus minus 1 which is 2
in other words greens theorem says that
the integral around the closed curve in
this case is twice the area of the
region R you see without the 2 in here
this would just be the area of the
region R since 2 is a constant factor we
can take it outside the integral sign in
other words in terms of a picture if I
want to find the area of the region R
and I want to use a line integral I need
only take what 1/2 of this integral in
other words the area of the region R is
1/2 the integral around the boundary of
our x dy minus y DX pay and again I will
drill on that in the homework the one
remaining thing I want to point out
before we get to a specific example is
how we remove the restriction of the
region being simply connected you see
what I claim is is that we may replace
simply connected by connected since
multiple connected regions are unions of
simply connected ones with cuts whatever
that means I'm let me show you what I'm
saying here look at this multiple
connected region here what I'm saying is
suppose I were to cut this region I can
then visualize this as the union of two
simply connected regions in fact if I
have a piece of paper in my pocket I
think we might as well the entire two
parts of calculus are almost over and
I've never done an experiment for you
here's one I think even I can handle
here's a connected region it's a piece
of paper I'll fold it and I'll now make
it it's simply connected because there
are no holes in it I will now undo that
I will make the region connected but now
multiple-- connected you see there's a
hole in it and all I'm saying is if I
cut this region
necessarily along a straight line all
I've got to do is to cut it if I cut
this region then what I have are two two
simply connected regions that can be
viewed as being fit together this way
but to see them clearly we can just
separate them but the reason I want to
cut them for you is to see that I can
actually fit these together and notice
that the cut that joins these two from a
theoretical point of view has no
thickness right that's just a line that
joins these two and here's the key point
you see physically certainly if I put a
cut inside the region the resulting
picture is different than with the cut
missing in other words I can distinguish
between the shape that I've drawn
without the accentuated chalk mark in
here and the shape that I have with the
accentuated chalk mark in here but
here's the key point first of all as far
as computing a double area is concerned
the cut having no thickness has zero
area so if somehow I were to compute the
area of the region R without the cut I
would expect to get the same area or if
I were to compute whatever you want to
call this the density or what have you
if I want to compute the mass of the
region R with the cut it should be the
same as the mass without the cut because
the difference is essentially what a set
of points which has zero area and by the
way for those of you who may read ahead
in mathematics and have heard such
expressions as lebesgue integral the
lebesgue integral on the like these are
things defined on sets of measures 0 but
what these things mean from an intuitive
point of view is essentially what we're
talking about now you see here are
infinitely many points on this cut and
yet the important thing is that with
respect to area these points even though
they're infinite number contribute no
area in other words there are infinitely
many points on the line but a line
having no thickness has no area so
certainly putting the cut in does not
affect the double integral on the other
hand since we always assume that the
read the region is kept on ala and I
left as we go around it turns out that
from the single integral the line
integral point of view
the each cut cancels because of opposite
sense what I'm saying is if I take this
region and slice it you see how do I
Traverse this piece since I want the
area to be enclosed on my left I
Traverse this region in this particular
direction when it comes to this piece I
Traverse this region in this direction
so the area isn't closed
to my left when I now superimpose these
two what happens is since this line
integral and this line integral go
exactly over the same curve remember I
just separated these so I could see them
better when I push these together this
is the same line since they have the
same function the same points but only
opposite sense these two integrals
cancel in other words if I'm given a
region that's multiple connected I can
view it like this meaning I go around
this piece this way so that my region is
on my left I go around the outside
border this way so the region is on my
left and when I want to use greens
theorem all I do is essentially I don't
even have to make the two cuts here I
could even make one cut and look at this
as the union of C well the two is C if I
make just the one cut and leave the line
out there are no longer any holes in the
region here but that's not the important
point the important point is that to
visualize the integral that I want are
the regions I want all I have to do is
put the cut in and whatever the cut does
is canceled out in the statement of
greens theorem in other words again that
quite often in using greens theorem we
still apply it to multiply connected
regions the reason that we stress simply
connected is that the proofs that are
given for greens theorem are easiest to
handle in the case of simply connected
regions and then we simply generalize it
to multiple connected by pointing out
what we just did here that we can always
visualize a multiple connected region as
a union of simply connected regions if
the appropriate cuts are made and again
that will be emphasized in the exercises
I thought that what we should do to
finish off today
lesson would be to actually do a trivial
exercise by Privia I mean Green's
theorem has profound application it's
more than just relating line integrals
to multiple integrals the applications
of these things are enormous and we're
going to hit a few of these in the
exercises but what I wanted to do is to
pick sort of a straightforward example
just to have you see what greens theorem
means when we translate it into a
concrete situation and the example I
have in mind is simply this let's
compute the line integral around the
closed curve C y cubed DX plus X to the
fourth dy where the curve C happens to
be the following simply closed a closed
curve I start at the origin and move to
the point 1 1 along the parabola y
equals x squared then I move from 1 1 to
0 1 along the line y equals 1 right and
then I move from 0 1 down to 0 0
along the line x equals 0 the boundary
of this is what I'm calling my region C
my curve C notice that the region are
enclosed by C lies on my left as I
traverse the boundary of C and what I
want to do is to find the value of this
line integral along this particular
closed curve C and again if you want to
see this in terms of our lecture of last
time where we talked about work and
force imagine that my force is defined
in the XY plane at any point X comma Y
to be Y cubed I plus X to the fourth J
etc meaning D are as usual will be DX I
plus dy J and what we're saying is that
this particular integral represents the
work that would be done if a particle
were starting at the point 0 0 and being
moved along the curve C so that it
returns to the point 0 0 now keep in
mind Millie
because the particle is returning to the
same point from which it started is not
enough to guarantee that the work done
is zero in fact the guarantee that would
be necessary would be that the partial
of y cube respect to Y would have to be
identical to the partial of X to the
fourth with respect to X and that
certainly isn't the case in this
particular example we don't have a
conservative force field in this case in
this case we suspect that the work done
should depend on the path connecting the
points in particular if we go around a
closed path the work done would not have
to be zero at any rate that's enough lip
service paid to the physical
interpretation of this let's actually
try to solve this problem and what we're
going to do is solve it in two ways the
first way will be to emphasize greens
theorem we'll solve it first by greens
theorem because that is the sermon for
today and the second method will be to
show how we would have solved the same
problem if we didn't have greens theorem
the idea being I won't tell you which of
the two ways one should have done this
the important point from the from our
point of view is that the two methods
yield the same answer
at any rate to use greens theorem notice
that M is y cubed n is equal to X to the
fourth so the statement of greens
theorem which says that the integral
around the closed curve C MDX plus NDY
is the double integral around the region
enclosed by C the partial of M and with
respect to X minus the partial of M with
respect to Y da that leads to this ok
and now what is my region a I'll think
of it as being a dy DX and if I look at
my region a I observed that for a fixed
value of x y varies from the curve y
varies from the curve x squared - 1 and
x + 2 n varies anyplace from 0 to 1 so
the line integral that I'm trying to
evaluate is this particular double
integral by the way we don't really need
this what comes next because from here
on in this would be old hat but just by
way of review
notice that I could have written this
with the order of integration reversed
so that I wouldn't have to worry about
an x squared in the lower limit I might
like all of my lower limits to be zero
that was I could have picked a
horizontal strip and shown that for a
fixed value of Y X varies from zero to
the square root of Y and y varies from
zero to one in any event this is just
garnishing we this is the easy part
all I'm saying is we now evaluate this
iterated integral integrating respect to
X the integrand becomes x to the fourth
minus 3x y squared evaluated between x
equals zero and x equals the square root
of y that of course leads to y squared
minus 3y to the five-halves
I integrate that between 0 and 1 I get
1/3 Y cubed minus 6/7 Y to the 7 halves
and as Y goes from 0 to 1 this becomes
minus 11 21st by the way again I hope
it's clear from previous exercises that
the minus sign simply has physical
significance that all we're saying is is
that one would expect that if the motion
takes place in the direction of the
force the force is helping us move the
particle whereas if the force is taking
place opposite to the direction of
motion we have to push against the force
to get the particle there so what we're
saying is in one case the sense is
positive the other is negative I'm not
going to worry here physically about
what the meaning of the minus sign is
but using greens theorem we have shown
what that the integral around the closed
curve see as we've defined see before y
cube DX + X 40 y is minus 11 21st and
what I would like to do now to finish
today's lesson is to do the same problem
only doing it without greens theorem and
again the point is to do this problem
without using greens theorem remember
what my region was over here without
having to refer back to the previous
what I'm doing is my curve C consists of
three separate line integrals see one is
the curve y equals x squared as X goes
from 0 to 1 c2 is the curve y equals 1
where X varies from 1 to 0 and the
of c3 is x equals zero and y varying
continuously from one to zero at any
rate using the fact that if a curve is
the union of curves that the line
integral around that curve is the sum of
the integral over the curves making up
the Union I get that the line integral
along c y cube DX plus X to the fourth
dy is the sum of these three line
integrals in other words I integrate
along c1 c2 and c3 where c1 is y equals
x squared and X varies continuously from
0 to 1 c2 is the line y equals 1 and X
varies continuously from 1 to 0 c3 is
the line x equals 0 and y varies
continuously from 1 to 0 using the
concepts that we talked about in the
last lecture for example to evaluate
this integral this will be what I
replace Y by x squared dy by 2x DX and
integrate as X goes from 0 to 1 so my
first integral is simply integral from 0
to 1 X to the 6 DX plus X to the 4th
times 2x DX ok my second integral coming
back to here Y is constantly 1 alright
so dy is 0 that makes this term drop out
consequently this term becomes what 1 DX
as X varies continuously from 1 to 0 so
that integral becomes integral 1 to 0 DX
and my final integral over C 3 notice
that for that integral X is 0 so both
this term and this term drop out see X
is 0 so this term drops out the fact
that X is a constant makes DX equal to 0
so this term drops out so my integrand
is just 0 dy as Y goes from 1 to 0 and
to make a long story short here this
integrand is simply X to the 6 plus 2x
to the fifth DX from 0 to 1 this is
simply another way of writing minus
one this is zero so my line integral
along the closed curve C is 1/7 X to the
seventh plus 1/3 X to the sixth
evaluated between 0 & 1 minus 1 this
comes out to be a 7th plus 1/3 which is
10 21st minus 1 makes this minus 11 21st
and hopefully that checks with the
answer that we got by the previous
method and at any rate if nothing else
that is an application as to how greens
theorem works now what this does as far
as this lecture is concerned and the
exercises will bring this out is it ties
in line integrals with multiple
integrals that will be the last lecture
of this particular block of material and
in the next lesson what we will do is
introduce a new block of material we in
particular shall talk about complex
numbers and that will occupy us for a
little while and at any rate though
until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate